hey there everyone I'm at CERN in Geneva
now CERN's famous for like the Large
Hadron Collider and all that physics but
it's also famous for something else
which I'm sure a lot of you are thinking
of and just in there is a really cool
sort of piece of history come and follow
me and I'll show you here we go
where the web was born so basically this
corridor is where the world wide web was
developed Sean the coder pretty cool let
me summarize this because it's quite
detailed basically it says around 1990
in a couple of other buildings Tim
berners-lee among the others came up
with the ideas and then in 91 it was all
pretty much consolidated to this
corridor so look at these guys
desecrating a sacred site basically this
corridor still used it's still a working
place for CERN this isn't a museum or
anything you look at all these officers
off to the sides people just doing their
work but it was here from 91 onwards
that Tim berners-lee
and his team developed the world wide
web here at CERN all to do with
accessing documents and things like that
we all know what it's become since and
it was around 94 that these people
basically broke off from CERN and
developed the web proper but it all
started here pretty cool hey and those
are the actual pipes that the internet
travels down so if I turn this here that
will turn the internet off I better not
touch that
from your office and it can end up on a
computer that's completely at the other
end of the world and then comes back to
you with the result and all this demand
that exists at different points of the
world at different times of day is then
equalized so that this whole structure
is used efficiently so this is like the
most advanced organization on earth
where the worldwide web was invented and
that's the telephone